foreign
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight at 11 o'clock I'm Sasha
Loftis we start with the latest in our
election results the decision desk
calling the race for U.S Senate today
Catherine Cortez masto is the projected
winner this ensuring Democratic control
in the Senate she gained over 14 000
votes in today's count giving her an
almost 5 000 vote lead over Republican
Adam laxalt she will be delivering
remarks tomorrow morning at 9 30 at the
Carpenters international trading center
and before election results came out
many questions during this morning's
election briefing related to safety Joe
Gloria of the Clark County Registrar of
Voters says the 2020 election was a
learning curve for his staff and for
volunteers this year many new actions
were put in place Gloria is saying he
hasn't heard of any issues because
police and security have been working
overtime to keep staff and volunteers
safe
we did what we did back in 2020 because
we learned that was a learning
experience and we took advantage of what
we learned then to put that into place
so lvmpd North Las Vegas Police Clark
County Park police they've done an
excellent job of keeping my staff safe
and in case you missed it the AP has
confirmed Republican Sheriff Joe
Lombardo will win the race for governor
rather defeating Democrat Steve sisalak
sisalak issuing this statement to his
supporters this week quote it appears we
will fall a percentage point or so of
winning obviously that is not the
outcome I want but I believe in our
election system in democracy and
honoring the will of Nevada voters we
know Joe Lombardo is planning a speech
in the coming days he had this to say
this week I've dedicated my life to
protecting and serving our community now
I'm honored to have the opportunity to
protect and serve our entire State as
your next governor we also know the
Democrat Dina Titus has defeated
Republican Mark Robertson today
Robertson officially conceded Victory to
Titus Democrats continuing that momentum
Susie Lee also winning District 3 over
Republican April Becker as well as
Democrat Stephen Horsford winning over
Republican Sam Peters in District Four
the Republicans did score a victory for
lieutenant governor Stavros Anthony
defeating Elizabeth Connell Burkhead
despite Burkhead winning here in Clark
County